Informatics for integrating biology and the bedside, i2b2,
is an NIH funded effort based at Partners Healthcare System in Boston.
Its mission is to enable clinical investigators to conduct
research using state of the art genomics and biomedical informatics.
i2b2 supports complex clinical research environments.
But it provides an easily understood database schema that can be used to create
a data warehouse where
large clinical abstracts from an enterprise EHR can be stored for future analysis.
This is important because the database schema of
commercial enterprise EHR can be dauntingly complex,
proprietary and not necessarily designed well to support ad hoc queries.
As shown here, i2b2 implementations are comprised of cells
that communicate via web services and in aggregate form in i2b2 hive.
The role of most of these cells should be clear from their names.
Custom cells can be added to the hive and there is
an organized i2b2 users group to share information
and applications and to create the potential for
research collaboration and federated queries across institutions.
Here, you see the addition of a fire cell to support smart and fhir apps running against
the data in the i2b2 instance. All right, just keep going.